[Music]
getting tired yet or what you slow down
ever no that you know when you when you
get to slow down in perpetuity oh [ __ ] i
was just making sense
you know the fact that one day we will
all die and then you're just sleeping
forever makes me kind of think like [ __ ]
it let me just squeeze this at bat yeah
but also doesn't it make you sometimes
think like [ __ ] it i'm not gonna do all
this
this is like this is where all the
garyvee content comes from
that's how i felt in school that's how i
would feel if you told me to make my bed
right right in your bed right you know
the most inefficient thing of all time
ever
well i see i'm i go [ __ ] back and
forth with it because you get
brainwashed by big bed who's like make
you better you'll be surprised well it
is it is undeniably more comfortable
yeah that's true
but you know how to fix that air
conditioning yeah
it's cold it's that's true
feels good yeah
so no but like honestly on some real
[ __ ] i
love
being an entrepreneur i love being an
operator i love doing my thing yeah and
if i go into any second of because i'm a
human being of like this blows
a
i don't try to like rah-rah myself it's
okay to have a bad day mm-hmm it's okay
to have like especially when it's
raining
[ __ ] rain like i don't know how those
seattle dudes do everything
yeah that is some depressing [ __ ] year
round is like some weird [ __ ]
like where where's like home home for
you right now new york new york you stay
here right here uh
but like
rain
gets me like rain's like my kryptonite a
little bit like it's really rainy and
like i like and i'm a little tired [ __ ]
it's done oh
no but like i really fight that first
hour anyway nonetheless i was only there
in college the second it was like and
like when i was in college i was working
out i was like well i'm not going to
class i was working out and the second
there was rain it was like dude we're
not going to go
all right it's
it just becomes tv watching day could
you ever do like la west coast somewhere
where it's nice all the time like you
know
you know it's funny at 46 now i'd be
lying if i didn't say the last five
years that i've gone to miami in la when
i would wake up like if i have to give a
keynote if i'm having a meeting if i
flew in the night before
when i wake up and like kind of open the
hotel you know right and that sunshine
hits my chest like a beam i'd be lying
if i didn't say
oh this is how people get i get it yeah
to live here right you know like i
definitely but also those places i feel
like
don't match you like no they don't
matter listen i'm pretty funny i'm high
energy i go hard on the field but like
when i'm off the field like using a
sports analogy i i love relaxing yeah
i'm what i am is all in or all out right
right my ideal vacation is 10 days on
the beach do nothing right okay are you
resort though on a beach
obviously yeah i can't do it
you got to feel the culture oh shut the
[ __ ] up
bro i don't want to go [ __ ] i don't
want to go to the caribbean to hang out
with some dude from new hampshire like
that's not fun i want to [ __ ] meet
people who are from there you want to
now meet people yeah [ __ ] people no not
not like not like i don't want to i
don't want to necessarily have like a
one-on-one conversation like tell me
your story man
around that i want to be around like
like i feel like i'm like okay i'm
experiencing something i actually do get
that that makes sense yeah i mean i do i
like both don't get me crazy i'm not
trying to just like stay in there
in like the middle of nowhere but i like
to like like every time i'm at a resort
if i'm sitting at a resort bar i'm like
i [ __ ] hate all of you yeah because
like we just all move it's all yeah
you're you're all me and i hate you all
in that scenario do you hate yourself
yeah yeah come on
we've
[Laughter]
you've won
[Laughter]
for the first time my life took a step
back oh i didn't i i decided to go the
other way you went all in i feel i could
feel all the homies taking a step back
because i get it yeah because even my
body was like it's time to take a step
back and i said no step back monster
yeah i'm gonna double down yeah you
always so i'm like
but i think you made the right move and
maybe i'm just drinking the cooling
again but i feel like
there's actually something brewing and
now i'm almost mad at myself for taking
this exactly there's something broke but
i actually i felt brother i felt great
i was like i was a different person a
hundred percent not having this like
dread every day do you know why i even
understand why people get mad at each
other over politics is sports yes yeah
it's the same [ __ ] it's just like rooney
for the team i am so upset that the
world has become so blue and red and all
i'm trying to do is be like
[ __ ] it's purple every one of
you are purple like of course you
believe in like and like we need that
because we're just going right yeah and
then in sports i'm like well
now now i understand yeah
exactly and i'm really but that's no
that's what's scary about politics is
that it's becoming maybe it always has
been but we're just realizing it but
it's becoming more like sports which is
the most irrational thing that we do
scream and yell at each other
yeah i mean the level of hate i have for
poor mac jones for no reason nice guy
great dude he was like die in a fire bro
at least brady was like fiery and like
whatever it was easier like this poor
doof is just walking around smiling one
of the nicest things that new england
has ever done for the new york franchise
is hiring not hiring mack jones
drafting mac jones because when those
when those pictures of him has like a
model came out like that's perfect
fodder
him on the runway doing like the things
like that he's probably had that [ __ ]
too brilliant early on yeah brady had
that where he was at carnevale with
gisele
and griffin yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no i think i think that um
i think that i went all in
and as you know this is the best if
you're smart if you're like a good
football fan you understand things this
is the best a jets fan could feel in a
very long time you don't know the full
answer at quarterback right you'd be
lying if you did
though his last five games were totally
different than the beginning of the
season
but what what you do know already if
you're a real football fan is elijah
elijah moore can play football
michael carter can play football elijah
vera tucker can play football right even
like the brandon uh michael carter the
two
at from duke can play foot like and what
what really resonates for me is the joe
sala combo and drafting like i am i
can't even tell you joe had a big draft
and joe i feel like he needed it because
the tie was about to turn and that draft
is it's been huge for him and they have
top five money
they have
four picks in the top 38. and we've had
that before but i i never trusted the
people in place to spend that money i
think mike mccagnin is the worst gm in
nfl history i don't know
it was pretty bad brother this is where
jeff fans get confused by branding the
izzyk thing feels bigger yeah but
mccartney was way worse yeah it's walked
into mike t's and i love mike t yeah but
he walked into a mess yeah he had to
clean it up right he blew his draft pick
those 12 picks he blew it which [ __ ]
us comma
mike had five years right mike mike
passed on patrick mahomes when we needed
a quarterback and took jamal adams yeah
like nobody taught we didn't have a
quarterback
josh mcallen like i don't understand
what people are josh mccown was the
quarterback of the jets he was the
income he was
on the board
it was actually ryan it was ryan
fitzpatrick
it's patrick and mcgowan
it's just insane what the jets
did under mike he completely decimated
the franchise you know sam darnold is
one of my favorite human beings but if
he doesn't go and turn around quick here
the jets traded multiple low round picks
to get sam right like he decimated the
franchise he gave a ton
so i feel like you you you stay pretty
positive even though like i know you
know that stuff right like i i stay
realistic i like i i'm pr listen i might
be positive publicly if you were hanging
out in my apartment when the jets play
i'm a [ __ ] disaster that's a good
question at one point uh
i think i know the answer already but
like
you
you're a businessman entrepreneur and
all that but now you're also just kind
of like a
influencer star you know what i mean
it's almost like uh more people know who
i am right but you know i'm saying like
um like when jim cramer became like jim
cramer the tv guy and no longer
financially
i say like where are you just like i'm
trying to put out content versus i'm
trying to make business that's a really
interesting question i
don't even think in those terms right i
am just navigating
i it all kind of like i kind of have
this big framework of like my ambitions
and my selfless agenda meaning i want to
buy the new york jets i'm a businessman
i'm trying to do [ __ ] like i'm deep web
3 because i think it's the future like
i'm putting in the time because that's
an opportunity i run a humongous company
with 1800 employees like i like i'm
trying to build an empire
comma
i have a personality trait that is
unusual for an empire building assassin
i which is i'm not tearing down
everybody around me i'm not a sharp
elbows i'm a nice guy's actually finish
first dude
and at some point i realized enough
people were watching me that i'm like
[ __ ] it let me like really teach people
that this is possible that you can be
very successful and happy and you don't
have to be a dick face
and so and so
what ended up happening was
a lot of things happen uh trash talk my
garage sale videos what is that that is
hundreds of people thousands of people
tens of thousands of people emailing me
over a period of time saying gary you
keep talking about investing in startups
but i don't have twenty five thousand
dollars in fact i'm six thousand in debt
and i have ninety three dollars in my
bank account what do i do and you know
you're getting this constantly and at
some point you're sitting on a plane and
saying [ __ ] i gotta do something
and i was like all right i'm going to
show them what i did when i had 93
dollars my garage saled and sold stuff
on ebay right and
anything your mouth is yeah and so like
so like so the whole like like
everything i do publicly has been really
counter-punching a lot of the energy
that i've been feeling it is i mean that
is a uh i feel like one of your biggest
criticisms is almost like you're not
going to make it dude like why why are
you telling these people it's like i
show you how to actually get there yeah
like a tangible way yeah just be like
follow your dreams like go to a [ __ ]
garage sale to make some yeah like like
people that to your point people that on
social media are like okay like razz me
and you're like okay i'm like cool but
like you've decided to look at that
video did you watch the videos that i
put out for an entire 18 months
detailing that tick tock was the next
big arbitrage and if you do this and if
you do that like like i'm very happy
that you've selected to clip a couple
things to fit your agenda right right i
mean everybody nobody actually watches
anybody's full episode or or catalog or
either by the way it's why i'm also
empathetic to people that think i suck
or [ __ ] you gary i'm like no that's what
they say right cause i'm like i get it
we
always like when people like uh you know
do your research it's like no people
don't do their research they look at the
headline they look at the video and they
make the decision i completely
understand why people hate barcelona
yeah i guess yeah you looked up you've
seen
what he do yeah absolutely so so i'm
very empathetic to that i don't take it
personally it's easier if it was like
when it's the company when you're the
human as you guys know sometimes it's
bar stool sometimes it's you yeah when
it's you you know for me the big key is
not listening in either direction
meaning when i talk about like putting
your fingers in your ears and like that
go into your own cocoon and do it for
yourself
it really really works against hate
but i'm not saying it for hate i'm not
saying for the haters i'm actually
saying it for the people that tell you
you're the goat good yeah because
there's a lot of that too i get way more
of that yeah and i heard you uh
described as a joe rogan for nerds
i think that's awesome i mean like i i
look i think that i get way more love i
know because i have the data
uh
but i don't hear that either yeah well
that that can almost be more dangerous i
feel like sometimes well this is my
leader
when you get high in your own supply
you're finished but there's got to be
that in between
that actually one of my biggest regrets
of my career is yeah one of my biggest
regrets especially because we do comedy
is i'm i'm always a little i'm way more
self-deprecating than i am i'm never one
to be like we did it or whatever you
know and i kind of wish i was a little
bit more over the last like 15 years
because i think people started to kind
of
you know yeah reciprocate that vibe
right and wait a minute i can say it not
you [ __ ] off you know a hundred percent
here's some good news
how old are you 36 that's almost 37.
this is perfect
when i was 34 years old i worked in a
liquor store yeah
like yes i keep trying to remind people
like oh you know people love like listen
one of the fun things like my favorite
thing right now is these five or six
comedians that fully impersonate me [ __ ]
is so funny yeah and they look like
you're very you got to laugh i got a lot
of
things to do yes yeah yeah the one guy
when he added the but i bite my name
these [ __ ] are so good
it's like it's like saying a child like
they know exactly exactly how to get and
and for me it's like truly like this is
where i'm lucky like
i'm flattered yeah like when they're
like making fun i'm flattered but what
you know one of the their favorite
sticks like the cliche go-to if you're
gonna impersonate me as 80 year old
person comes up to me and i'm like how
old are you 80. you got [ __ ] tired
and it's funny i get it it makes me
laugh
you know what's bananas [ __ ] though i
believe it's so much you couldn't
imagine it yeah
if you really understood when i you said
36 to me what my brain did
it's
so uncomfortably early yeah like
we're going to die
it is we were talking about this
recently like some of those with someone
we're just like we're just talking about
smells like how like it's so weird that
like you'll never experience what it's
like for me like just like you wouldn't
even know what that smells like to me
like how oh it's me my mom cause my
mom's like a really like sensitive nose
and i'm like you walking like i don't
smell anything like walking around she's
like you don't know how horrible it is
when i walk in the room yeah and
and like you don't know what's like in
my head right here
that i'm 33 i'm like that's over dude
like i don't know i guess i'll ride this
out until i die and that's it dude
i got nothing
on some real [ __ ] we're obviously having
fun with this
if if people understood how much that
thing
is the thing
like how that [ __ ] up people like
people generally it's too late depressed
in their 30s and 40s which is insane
and they're not going to listen to their
60 year old parent
like you don't listen to your parent
ever and so for me it's like you know
it's just something i believe in i wish
people understood it it goes down to
accountability it goes into like
realizing you can shift on a dime
it's like it's very real i try to use
like
the rock and like marky mark and like
the fresh prince i try to use like these
people that are fully converted like all
three people i just mentioned we in
america were like oh that's marky mark
yeah like he's got abs and underwear and
he's cool like his rapper like but then
he's a mark wahlberg like the real
powerhouse like you know dwayne like
like i wish people just knew like [ __ ]
evolved
back third act 10 you really can you
really can like if you really and when
you said that like i felt it to be frank
like i'm empathetic to like
hey i can say it but don't you say it
especially because i've worked my face
off for 15 years and like it's really
fun ricky in ohio 19 years old you're
saying that well like we also we do a
lot of like you know we're lucky to be
here and just [ __ ] around on the mics
this isn't a hard job blah blah blah but
like it is you know i mean like we put a
lot into it but then which is why people
are just going off
of us which is why you could do a little
bit of what like if you want and this
will help people
if you want you can use a different
social platform to
educate a little bit for example one of
the most remarkable things you two could
do is actually put out occasional
content of like what you've learned of
how to be better at doing this
like there's a lot of kids 15 that want
to be you with all their heart and like
one video of like hey i sucked at this
and i got better at this and this is why
that just might help somebody right you
don't want to help anybody i don't think
i ever got better
[Laughter]
like your greatest
challenge if you if you did i had no
problem helping you you did like
entrepreneur therapy sessions like six
sessions with him and try to turn
it's like turn around titanic i'll tell
you why
when you're a boston fan
no this is real this is real people
don't understand this is why i'm so
worried about it
if you're a 33 year old boston fan never
experienced any any any anything you
know it's worse you think you did
something
yeah but you're a big guy see i i think
that's i think there there certainly is
a person but i'm like we suck
that's the difference it's better than
that you know like
what do you mean when you like like i
get that as a knock but like as like a
genuine christmas like i don't think
anyone there's a handful of people who
think definitely and then they're
they're psyched
it's a hair subconscious you're getting
the you're getting the winner endorphin
hit from your family i'm important for
sure thinks he's superior to other
people because he's like no he's always
thought that that's just that's just
dave yeah
that's just dave as a person what do you
think of portnoy i love him yeah yeah i
think he's been he's very underrated
underrated over very importantly yeah i
think he's underrated i think much
by the way all of us me you two him it's
all the same game like people decide
something without really peeling back
the onions oh yeah i mean like building
something like pornoid built a media
company in the most contemporary way
that will always resonate with somebody
like me that is my overall thesis of
business what would be uh your number
one critique of barcelo or dave i guess
but us as a whole
you know what's funny and like i'm not
trying to be overly nice it's it's just
not something i pay attention like i
don't i don't have a great answer like i
don't know like if i could see your p l
well sure i could be like you overspend
on x or you oh yeah yeah you probably
see a lot of that yeah
you know but like but like but like for
all from all the public look in a
political climate that we're in now
anything like this is gonna feel too
male into the macro world but that i
think is unfair because i think there's
plenty of things that are too female and
and people talk about that and i think
that's unfair like to me the criticism
would come from missed opportunity
not from what you've actually executed
right you know what i mean
have been where i missed an opportunity
not because when you have a level of
that success like was the right was the
sale that you guys did was that the
right exit strategy uh was was there
categories you missed were you too slow
to tick-tock like like you know uh i'll
give you one the ready if you're like no
no gary let's go deeper on this don't
give us a [ __ ] answer the we're
gonna give you the p l do you know the
first place i would go i would look at
your merchandise business here's why
i think you guys
and gals do merch so much better than
every
other media company so it doesn't seem
like the obvious place i would go but my
point of view is you might not be
maximizing it to the highest degree
that if good lord if there's more
there's more emerges to come well i can
tell you that they're definitely you can
definitely do more like just back to
like not fully looking but like you guys
aren't doing all the best practices on
getting like your influencer merch pr
like strategy should be way stronger
like you should have every single piece
of merch you do
4 000 tick tock long tail influencers
should be rocking them
don't do that buddy you don't do that
yeah so like that
that's where my
that's what i get nerded about not like
you shouldn't have said that right right
or like that like that's just dumb [ __ ]
yeah yeah what what what about uh my
favorite garyvee moment ever the uh
the shoot your family in the face
dude honestly like back to like the way
media works so earnestly because i
believe in it
you know unfortunately this is where
tick-tock can really [ __ ] you yeah yeah
yeah
i spent 18 months blessing out how to
[ __ ] screw myself
i'm like you know even dustin's here
like dust you know we might have to
rethink our tick tock strategy because
because the way you could you know me
stitched out of context
it's gold but then you should stitch
their stitches and go right back at it
it's amazing 100
look i i
i think that
uh it's very easy
to take things out of context
i i believe
that if you think about i believe that
the world is not grateful
and i think that the world needs a lot
more gratitude and i think for me
when i think about things when i'm upset
about dumb [ __ ]
if i think about
somebody had something horrible happen
today i actually on a much more somber
note we had a very very very tragic
event happen at vayner last week we lost
an employee to a horrific situation
that's all i've been willing to share
it sucks look even just saying it takes
the air out of this room it's real life
like real [ __ ] happens like somebody
just now lost a child in at birth like
like life happens and like when you do
what i just did it you know it
here it sucks the room out of a fun
moment not fun but if you're having a
really bad day around dumb [ __ ] like
i didn't go viral on social media this
month or
my coffee's cold
like the subway sucks or eh like my bus
is later and like like dumb [ __ ] that
everybody complains about
if you go to that extreme place of like
yeah but this could have happened i
actually do think it helps people with
perspective sure
people aren't good at the easy way
like i'm giving them the extreme like
think about like something tragic and i
understand that people are like what the
[ __ ] is the matter with you
but i'll tell you what's the matter with
me when i tell you to be grateful for
what you have everyone's like yeah on to
the next thing like people don't do well
yeah they don't like they're like
people take everything for granted
everything 850 million people on earth
don't have access to clean water we have
[ __ ] seven [ __ ] bottles of body
armor [ __ ] shout out body armor we have
700 [ __ ] bottles of body armor in
here like on the shelf half drank
[ __ ]
850 million people on earth don't have
access to clean water the [ __ ] are you
complaining about
i believe in that [ __ ] and that's what
makes me happy that's what doesn't allow
me to burn out it's real for me
and like you know i'll let people mean
me mock me make fun of me in perpetuity
i'm gonna pump this [ __ ] until my last
breath i have two agendas get people to
figure out how [ __ ] lucky we are and
win a [ __ ] super bowl
[Laughter]
i'm really excited about the jets
brother i and but but i can get really
unexcited fast let me explain how
everything is this offseason yeah
everything yeah everybody's going to
take a step forward everybody's going
like money has to fall in the place of
the drought has to come back and
everything
that's what's crazy though everything
has to click like that's all football
like that's uh
the jets like that's football in general
it's just like one thing goes wrong and
it's like that you're not if the rams
don't push you with the way the browns
don't cut obj i don't think the rams
wanna right it's like everything yeah
right breathing down we're talking real
football now right like yeah the browns
because the first couple plays in the
super bowl right yeah just like that
alone what about what about the impact
once woods got hurt on the season who
knows where the rams finish the season
look what happened to the cardinals
cardinals were there
were better than the rams in my opinion
at three-fourths of the way two halfway
through the season what happens to them
hopkins gets hurt late season's over
what happens to the rams woods gets hurt
that would have been a real problem the
way cup would have been covered after
that if they didn't have an alternative
but obj slides in he's his best self and
[ __ ] here we are yeah
you look like like yeah the butterfly
effect is crazy cause then you talk
stafford like then stafford's probably a
bad move because you lost picks until
2027
think about think about the bengals if
you're a bengals fan right now you're
[ __ ] chilling in the cut you're like
jamar chase
higgins bro you're
by the way dan marino made the super
bowl in his first or excuse me second i
think her first set year yeah never
again i thought i as i'm older than you
i'm like this is gonna win five this
fucker's gonna win seven this sucks he's
in our division
maybe never again right i look at i look
at look at the chiefs look at the bills
right look at the chiefs dude the afc
right now someone's going to be getting
shut out in the next few years well this
is the biggest problem we have no
there's got to go through here are the
following here are the following
quarterbacks that are under 27 years old
in the afc lamar jackson
josh allen yeah he's like the worst
justice right justin herbert yeah joe
burrow that's bad patrick mahomes i mean
this is chilly
right now
but by the way like there's a hair of
optimism on mac from patriot fans i mean
i still think particularly in the locker
room that's what i've said is that my
the most important thing for me is the
guys in the locker room are like he's
the guy so if they believe in it then
you know my my ability to evaluate a
quarterback is very low but
the patriots were a sneaky 10 and eight
yeah it's all said and done they were 10
and 8 and go through the on the next
show can you go through with him the 10
wins
because there's only two even decent
ones the other eight are straight
garbage and so like let's not get too
excited yeah there was a seven there was
a seven win streak that was like legit
mostly destroyed teams that's right by
the way the chargers win
it sold us now
the chargers win was very impressive the
titans win was impressed those are
impressive wins yeah um but the chargers
didn't make the playoffs and the titans
but you also annihilated the jets the
second time you annihilated jackson like
annihilated like 50 spots
um
and for belichick to have many seasons
without brady now five
where he's only won one playoff game
if the patriots go the next four seasons
and win no playoff games
i believe that the narrative on
belichick's career could get very weird
i think i think good i agree with that
and i was always uh higher if i was him
because he's done with this and not he's
such a [ __ ] but he knows he's a great
coach because he is defensive like he is
but the legacy in it
let's call his way to spade if they
don't if they don't if they don't win
a playoff game in the next four years
it's going to get worse
people like us
empire
just one subject
i think it'll happen in new england too
because the media is so a little you
know not doesn't love bill and then
there are fans who are die-hard brady
guys and so like like i've always been
more it's brady more than belichick
whereas dave's always it was more
belichick than brady and now that like
it was always fun because who cared it
didn't matter because we're both on the
same team we'll give you who it is now
that it's separate now that there are
you know there are uh
diverting beliefs in it then i i think
it will get pretty loud whether he was
actually a good quarterback or whether
he just got really lucky
let's hope we're doing that conversation
in four years
all those young quarterbacks are gonna
keep us out of the playoffs yeah it
might still make me happy i think i pull
off when i'm
i gotta get out of here boys great to
see you continued success
[Music]